[Music]
hey
it's us again we're back yeah we're uh
talking about a damn anthology movie
that we saw it's a pretty good one
can i tell you right now i loved this
movie yeah it's a good movie
it just made me they honestly wheel with
delight
they obviously saw a creep show and they
wanted it to be as great as that
and yeah it was it was good the
wraparound story was good and everything
the wraparound story had the dude that
played the krugen from highlander
clancy brown yeah well he's been in tons
of stuff
yeah he's done like a lot of uh voice
work and he's also he was also in uh
starship troopers he was in
[ __ ] uh i remembered him as being the
monster
in the bride do you remember that
frankenstein adaptation with [ __ ]
sting
bales in it i didn't see that one which
is kind of a guilty plea well it would
be a guilty guilty pleasure for me if i
was guilty of anything yeah
i mean it's a terrible movie but i kind
of love it but yeah he's in like
tons and tons of other stuff yeah he's
an old man now and they make him look
even funnier oh my goodness and he just
[ __ ]
he nails it he's kind of like a the [ __ ]
keeper in a certain way but you know he
doesn't need a whole lot of makeup just
his [ __ ] hair and just he's kind of
like the tall man too yeah
yeah but an angry scrim that can [ __ ]
deliver lines and act
[Laughter]
although you know angus scrum could act
a little yeah i was going to say why are
you casting those versions on
angus scrim yeah just that you know this
dude here is a much better actor
he's got it yeah and like i said he also
um he was in shawshank redemption too
yeah oh and he does mr krabs voice on uh
spongebob squarepants
and has done for a very long time yeah
um and he's been i think he did some of
the [ __ ]
i don't know he does like a lot of voice
over work too yeah but yeah so
uh in case we didn't mention it this is
called the mortuary collection
and um it's an anthology film it
premiered
halloween yeah and it's like and it's uh
premiered in 2019 like at fantastic fest
like last show about a year ago
uh it premiered and got pretty like very
positive reviews like across the board
and it seems like even like
you know google imdb and stuff like that
it's always like way up in the
80 90 percentage range it's got five
skulls on cheddar
it does and i can see why because this
movie
um you know the thing about a lot of
anthology movies and we've talked about
them before it's just kind of like
because a lot of times they'll do like
each story will be like directed by
somebody
else so you know it'll be like a little
uneven
now this one is a little bit different
in the sense that the whole thing was
directed by one guy
ryan spindell now as far as i know
this might be his first feature length
film now he did do a short film called
the babysitter murders which actually he
did remake for this
like he kind of incorporated into this
anthology story
but as far as i know that's the only but
i have to say
wow good [ __ ] job dude
yeah it's [ __ ] horrible this movie
was a blast it's like it's just
um and you can tell i think uh there was
a snippet of an interview with ryan's
mandel and he said basically this movie
was my love letter to ec comics like i
said that's why you get the creep show
thing
um and steven spielberg and like you
know movies from the 80s and like
all the old horror anthologies like from
the 70s and 80s which he always really
loved
um so he wanted to make something like
that like an homage to that
and i think he succeeded in that in
spades also has a little bit like
visually
a little bit of a tim burton thing but
not so tim burton you know what i mean
no the color palette is really good on
it this is a gorgeous
gorgeous looking shot composition and
all that looks good the wrap-around
story kind of looks like
uh looks kind of like a movie version of
the damn halloween
or other excuse me like the haunted
house out of them
disney world yeah it has a [ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] vibe
it's got a good got a good score
the storytelling straightforward and you
know [ __ ]
good uh each little story is real good i
liked it actually i think they kind of
got better as they went
is trying to build up one thing that i
liked that they did with this
is that like the wrap around story which
also ties in with the last story
is set in the 1980s but the stories that
go on like the first story set in the
50s the second one
set in the 60s the third one set in the
70s and then like the babysitter murders
which
ties in with the wraparound is 1980s so
it's almost kind of like four decades
and so you get like a really cool i mean
the production design and everything
like that is like really cool like the
way they did like they went from decade
to decade
but then it still has like an
overarching look to it i mean just
the whole thing was just it had that
beautiful
like greenish like tinge with just like
pops of like red and like fire light and
stuff like that and it's just i love
that [ __ ] look
yeah and it was also kind of homage and
italian giallo's
lighting styles in certain parts of the
story and up inside that house it's just
a good
good story you know [ __ ] second story
you had some damn jocks uh jocks trying
to get laid
it in college in the in the i guess it
was 50s or 60s
that was that one was 16. early 60s this
is funny how
they're using call marks to [ __ ]
empower women and hand out [ __ ]
birth control like [ __ ] robbers so
they can get laid you know like
yeah you empower yourself babe you know
if i can jump up on a bobo you know it's
[ __ ] hilarious
and [ __ ] i don't i can't spoil any of
the yeah i mean i'll just give like a
run down i'm not gonna this is like on
shutter they just added it
um you know and like i said shutter has
been really knocking out of the park
with the [ __ ] they've been like curating
and like adding on there recently yeah
this one was like the first this one
really like put me in the mood
like the halloween type of movie oh i
forgot if you guys have shutter i forgot
to mention this before i forget
they put the evil up there which is one
of my favorite [ __ ] horrors
we reviewed it a while back yeah yeah
[ __ ] my babysitter kimmy took me to
that
i saw that in the matinee with kimmy
[ __ ] princess leia
i saw that with princess leia but
[ __ ] that that
there was something about that movie and
it's got three or four different titles
but
uh the version i saw in california was
called the evil
and that's generally what it's not yeah
it is better than the amityville horror
it's a lot better than the amityville
horror yeah i liked it but go ahead and
check that out one out too
yeah they just added that one recently
to them but uh but yeah so
the the interesting thing about this too
is that thematically or i guess like the
the wraparound story is a similar setup
to
john carpenter's body bags from 1993 you
know what i'm saying
um not exactly the same but it's better
than body bags though uh yeah i think it
is well because like i said body bags
had different directors for each one and
so some of them were better this one was
like the same director so it had more of
a cohesive vision even though it was
like the stories were different
body bags had a good throwback appeal
though you know i mean that is a classic
yeah we reviewed that one too yeah
deborah harry and stuff all star cast
but
this one i think just like you said the
cohesiveness of it
the tonally and just visually this is
just a better looking movie
yeah i mean this is a great looking
movie and like i said it just puts you
it's not it's not even necessarily set
at halloween but it just puts you in
that spirit it's very autumnal yeah it
really just looks something you should
be seeing at halloween right alongside
trick or treat and maybe like [ __ ]
season of the witch or halloween three
i saw another reviewer say that they
were because because he said well i
watched trick-or-treat
you know every halloween night before
going to bed he's like i think i'm gonna
add this one as like
a double feature definitely a halloween
movie but it is big yeah because even
though it's not like overtly like oh
it's set on halloween but it has like a
very halloween tone that's what they're
talking about yeah and it's a very
autumnal tone
i was under the impression that this was
supposed to be watched at halloween yeah
that's just from the top yeah i mean
like the look of it and just like the
whole thing that works
you know the whole just like you said
it's tim burton but it's almost like you
said like the haunted mansion
like at disneyland it kind of has that
aesthetic can get a little sickly sweet
for me and visually it kind of looks tim
burton but does not have that tim
burton-y tone
yeah tim burton can kind of get on my
nerves sometimes even though he does
have some [ __ ] excellent movies
mars attacks [ __ ] things i need to
see mars attacks again i haven't seen
that in so long i love that yeah
so you know there is some stuff i think
he really knocks it out of the park
nightmare before christmas is also well
that's a classic class of that that he
did a good job on it
just to sum his stuff doesn't quite
do it yeah yeah it gets too tim burton-y
yeah yeah that's true yeah but yeah so
uh what we have here the setup of this
and the frame story which like i said
ties in with like the last story
you got clancy brown playing a mortician
named montgomery dark and he
runs this mortuary in a town called
raven's
end and i love just the setup of this
like i said it's very green and aqua and
it's like really cool looking and
there's like a little kid riding a bike
and it's like this creepy like there's
leaves blowing everywhere so this uh
young woman
named sam comes into the
mortuary ostensibly to apply for a job
because it was like a help wanted sign
so then they start um she wants
montgomery dark who she uh
calls monty just to be an [ __ ] um
she wants to she wants him to like tell
her some stories of like the people that
died so like i said in that sense that's
why it's why body bags
why it reminded me of body bags a little
bit was because that was set in a morgan
he was telling the story of each body
so it's kind of a little bit like that
where it's just kind of like we're
talking about
actually conceptually similar the
execution and tone very different
very very different yeah um so
so then we go into the first story which
is set in the 50s and is actually like
the shortest one
uh this is basically just about a woman
who's at a party she sneaks into a
bathroom
she's uh a pickpocket and uh something
terrible happens to her at the end
um and i want to say too that this is
very much like creep show easy comics
type of thing in the sense that it's
very much like
a shitty person gets their comeuppance
type of stories they're like morality
tales yeah you pay for what you do
right just essentially like creep show
is yeah um so that's like i said that's
the shortest one actually kind of more
of a vignette but like i said it's
really like
yeah the way they do each decade is like
really really cool
so then the second one yes hold on the
wraparound story is kind of important to
all this
like in this girl is trying to apply for
a job at the mortuary yeah i said that
okay yeah and he's telling a story every
time and she doesn't react to it she
thinks thinks the shit's lame so
she's like not impressed so she tells
her another one and keeps up in the ante
and so the wrap around really the
wraparound story is awesome
i really like the wrap it is i i do as
well and every time you tell a story she
goes oh come on and then he's like
like like the story i love quincy brown
so much he's so good at this
and then he starts coming at her a
different way and tells her another
story
but uh second story i really liked it
when it went
when this is the frat guys yeah when
this story came the first one was real
short i was like okay but it wasn't
really all that special
she reacted the same way though she's
like oh come on yeah so it has like a
little bit of a meta tone too yeah
she's kind of coming at it like so then
the second one
second story came and it was a lot more
interesting
all right and it also got a lot gorier
and stuff you know they went there yeah
on this one i was in there i was like
all right
and i was like i'm down i'm down okay i
laughed so hard at that
yeah so by the time the second one is
starting
when these dudes are trying to scam
their way up these girls [ __ ] skirts
back in the 60s using karl marx and
women's rights and empowerment to jump
on a motherfucker's dick
that's when i started to pay attention
i'm like yeah okay now what happened
because see i knew oh hippie dudes you
know as [ __ ]
who ended up being old auto mechanics
and they would tell hippy stories and
that's basically what it was you know
hey man let's go to the anti-war protest
and go uh you know
get some chicks yeah yeah it was
everything was just kind of a scam you
know
those dudes weren't those dudes were
just did it for the girls but anyway
they came at me with that angle and i
was like yeah that's right there's truth
to this so then
it's okay they get their issue it's a
[ __ ] that's a good story
i really really get that story that one
probably made me laugh the hardest
just because yeah she's so cruel does
these dudes get [ __ ] up
and i was just like the punishment
didn't really fit the crime
oh i don't know but
that's how it would be you know that's
how women are i tackled and cackled and
cackled
that's a good one though yeah i know i
like that we're the worst i did too
and like i said i like i mean even
though you could kind of guess where it
was going like we guessed where it was
going
yeah but you had to go that way but i
was
i was like curious because i'm like are
they really going to show
like what they're suggesting that
they're going to show and they did
and then as the stories be told get told
sometimes
characters from the earlier stories show
up so now you have a background
yeah like dr kubler who shows up in this
one he actually shows up in the next
story as well so a lot of the [ __ ] that
happens in the early stories ends up
impacting the later stories you're like
oh that's one of those i know where
those things came from yeah so
yeah so it kind of all ties together
yeah they all kind of like kind of like
creep show with the marble ashtray you
know i mean that turned up in like every
show like in different iterations or
different uh it's every bit as good as
creep show one
it's a different movie yeah but i'm
gonna put it at that level
and i you know i love anthology movies
um and
this and it's but like i said it's
usually like you see them and they're
just like oh this story was really good
but the other ones was kind of mad
but this one was just like just really
good the whole way through and like i
said i think it was because it was one
director
and so it was very cohesive yeah so
everything kind of like
tied together the movie fulfilled a
vision
yeah and you know it had like a similar
even though it went through different
decades like
it had a similar like look to it so then
the third story which is set in the 70s
there's this guy named uh wendell and
he's married to
uh his wife carol and she has some kind
of do they even
like specifically say like what's the
matter with her she has like some kind
of disease or something and she's like
comatose or she's like wasting away
and there comes a point where the doctor
who's the same doctor from the last
segment um basically comes and says you
know look she's like comatose she can't
you
he has to take care of her it's like but
she's stabilized we don't know you know
she might live like many many more years
you know maybe you should um think about
uh accidentally on purpose like giving
her an overdose or
just sting you know what i mean because
it's you know because this poor guy it's
like he has to take care of this woman
she can't
talk she can't do anything for herself
and it's like uh you know he he doesn't
know how much longer she's gonna live
and so he's like kind of bummed out
about it
and so uh basically um he's tries to do
that but it doesn't quite go the way he
expects and like um kind of terrible
[ __ ] happens
i will say this one is also it's a
slower burn but this one is kind of more
like
emotionally affecting i guess because
you can like think about
it's even though it's still you know
it's not a bummer it's not but it's like
has a little bit of sadness tinged too i
didn't like this
as much as the second one but it's still
a good movie yeah i mean well the second
one was much more comedic yeah
this one was like less comedic but it
was still
really gory still really um [ __ ] up
and i really really liked uh the
puppetry i guess that was a puppet that
they did at the end right like with the
corpse like the way he was seeing like
that looked really really cool
um i really really liked the way they
did that let me respond to some people
oh
con says we need a silver shamrock movie
yeah i'd love to see a
remake of halloween three just silver
shamrock kind of higher
and budget with a bunch of with a bunch
of uh you know
carpenter homages and stuff that that'd
be awesome um let's see what else going
on
yeah uh alex says yeah tom after a
certain point you want to tell tim
burton okay we get it yeah
i liked a lot of his movies but i mean
once he started going like i didn't
you know i didn't love alice in
wonderland um you know parts of it were
alright but i just
there was something about it didn't
really resonate i really really did not
like
uh his [ __ ] um willy wonka remake
that i
that just made me want to like throw
something at the wall
also saying that he uh he liked
christina ricci i liked christina ricci
back
i did as well i like christina ricci
back in the day before she got her boobs
lopped off
she was more appealing as a [ __ ]
short curvy chick but i
for some reason she thought i don't get
it
i don't get it she wants well maybe she
had breast cancer
no i don't think so i mean you know she
was a kid she may be 25
yeah but 25 year olds get breast cancer
too
i don't think i think they would have
mentioned something like that and then
she lost a whole bunch of weight she's
trying to be skinny you know what i mean
she was curvy little chick she was yeah
and i i thought she looked better like
that but yeah
whatever women in cocaine
okay um or just women and not eating
yeah
women are not eating well she's probably
up in hollywood and they probably had
dudes tell her that she was fat that's
well that's what i suspect probably
happens like you need to like lose 20
pounds for this role what are you
talking about
yeah she was maybe five feet tall you
know what i mean yeah she's a little
bitty
and she had a [ __ ] banging little
[ __ ] figure you know what i mean and
then i saw her the next time and she
looked like like a boy or something
[Laughter]
you know okay so yeah so after that
segment um we get oh so i just got a dis
thing that my package got delivered okay
so i guess there's a package out front
so i'll have to go get them
i don't know what it is i've ordered so
many things it's like it could be lots
of things
okay so after so after that um there's
like a little bit
we return to the frame story and it
turns out that the last segment uh
segment four which is called the
babysitter murders
actually ties into the character of sam
who has come there
ostensibly to look for a job at this
mortuary and so
that kind of goes in that direction now
like i said i think from what i read
ryan spendel the guy that directed this
um his short film the babysitter murders
i'm not sure how similar it is to this
but he like incorporated this into
the anthology film so this is about sam
it's set
up now like i said i don't wanna because
this one is like a twist
they all kind of i don't know i don't
want to say they all have a twist
because some of them like i said the
second one kind of goes the way you
expect it to but it's like really
satisfying nonetheless
it's for you um well yeah i know that's
what i just that's i just got an email
why would i be getting an email from
this for you
you know duh but yeah
she's [ __ ] with me live on live on
camera [ __ ] with me
all right go ahead [ __ ]
um but yeah so this one is set up like a
standard um
you know babysitter is babysitting a
little kid named logan
uh and there's an escaped mental patient
and stuff like that but
it does have a twist to it um
that i will not spoil maybe you can see
it coming i don't know i didn't really
see it coming
but um also really really good
gore in this one there is like one
actual there is one scene where
uh i'll say somebody's face gets smashed
with a tv
and it looks really gross and really
really good
so i will say that like the the special
effects in this are great
the acting is great like the stories are
great it looks
amazing um you know all the beautiful
like colors and everything like that
it's just so
reminiscent of like fall and halloween
and it just looks like the haunted
mansion and it's just like so so [ __ ]
cool
logan's trying to send a super chat but
he can't figure out how to do it
i don't know how to do it from this yeah
i don't actually know how to do that
either on my end well on my live chat
there's just like a little
like a little box at the bottom that has
like a little dollar sign in it which i
assume that's what you push but i'm like
scared to push it because i don't know
what's going to happen
i don't know what's going to happen no
con i haven't seen black snake moan i
heard that's a good movie i got to see
it
uh yeah i think i might have seen it
maybe or i've seen parts of it they're
saying christine
christina still looked hot back then she
had all the curves still i think it's
what one dude yeah
maybe it wasn't samuel jackson in that i
thought she had kind of gotten skinny by
that
by that point maybe not when did that
come out 97
ooh i can't remember a whole [ __ ]
thing was to be short with [ __ ]
boobs and delicious nice [ __ ] dyes on
her man
you know it's got its own appeal you
know you know how tom is with the boobs
and the boobs and the thighs
i like thick man
[Laughter]
thick with two c's well yes well i i
guess it was two states
i like the same white girls that black
guys like
yeah but yeah so
um so yeah they do the thing with the
babysitter murders
another thing that i like about this too
i'm just gonna say i'm not gonna like
say like which story is which thing but
it's like this has like i said people's
faces get smushed by tvs um people's
dicks explode
uh children get murdered it's
fantastic and i was just like i had such
a good time watching this like i'd had a
drink or two at that point but i still
remember it really good it's not like i
forgot it the next day um but i just had
like a [ __ ] blast watching this we
just had such a great time
watching this movie it's just yeah you
definitely got to see this one it's so
for for halloween what i would recommend
is you always want to go
for [ __ ] crepe show all right you
want to go
for uh trick or treat right and uh
this one would be good oh yeah add this
one to the rotation this one
uh a [ __ ] halloween three season of
the witch you want to put that one on
there
and i'd probably watch the evil i liked
the evil i think they'd make a good
halloween yeah
even though it's not like specifically
halloween thing no but that's good
halloween
you know what i've decided to do not
this week because uh this isn't
halloween week but next week this
halloween week
i'm gonna do like every day that we do a
live
matinee i'm gonna do like a newer
halloween
themed movie okay because and i found a
bunch i found like four
christmas for christmas man you gotta
watch [ __ ] christmas chronicles
christmas it's supposed to be christmas
chronicles too crustle part two
is gonna come out on netflix i need to
look that up and see
part two crystal part two yeah [ __ ]
right
the crustling
ii please somebody needs to brought you
by canon films
i want to see that [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ]
think you've had enough crustal you
haven't crushed the [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
until you've crustled to the crustling
crustle together with us
we crustle alone together
i can just i can imagine the [ __ ]
poster for that yeah
and it's got like 10 people in the
[ __ ] poster but each one of them's
got crosses faces
every character is played by crustle
yeah yeah yeah
it's like being john malkovich but like
a lady
but like an action movie first yeah
even plays the children and the dog
and the dog oh my god
crust all the motion picture
oh my god all right so uh so
yeah definitely if you have shutter or
you could probably get this uh
maybe you can get it other places on v8
too but it's definitely on shadow they
just added it called the mortuary
collection
i liked this so much that i kind that i
hope they do another one
actually i would like to see ryan
spindell do another one and like i said
if you like cream show if you liked body
bags if you liked
any of those really kind of like
halloweeny kind of like anthologies from
this and it has like a steven
spielbergie like 80's kind of vibe to it
too
it has a high-end 80s feel but with
modern technology
it's just a good [ __ ] movie yeah it's
just it's just a [ __ ] blast to watch
like from start to finish not boring i
think it's like
super gory it's super dark and it just
like looks fantastic
it's just a really fun movie sandra said
she liked christmas chronicles watched
it because we recommended it
i'm telling you i heard that christmas
chronicles 2 is coming out this
that's i heard that as well but like i
said i don't know if the if the
production got pushed back but it's like
i thought they were already working on
it
like last year's christmas chronicles 2
on netflix
i got to look back into it crustal
versus the yokai
yeah yeah yokai wars and yokai monsters
that
those are good movies i don't know they
don't really have a christmasy feat
or they don't have a halloween female oh
thank you so much logan oh my goodness
oh thanks logan brother wow help us pay
for them damn keys
yeah right 200 worth of car keys
yesterday yeah don't lose your car keys
kids for newer cars yeah and my car's a
2004.
yeah and we didn't lose the key we just
broke and the chip fell out
couldn't find a damn we said about it
last night i've been fixing that key
we've been gluing it back glued it back
together
yeah it didn't work and then well it did
for a while but then
and then and then kanavatsaland who's in
in chat right now he said he had to pay
that same price about a hundred dollars
a key in mexico
and he said in the mexican economy
that's like paid a thousand dollars for
the key said they said
they they he said a nerd shows up in a
damn van
bends you over a barrel tells you he's
going to use lube
no lubin and i said dude that's the same
[ __ ] that happened over here man
yeah but i figured because even when i
went to ace hardware and asked them
i was like can you um you know do this
key they're like yeah but it has a chip
and then we have to like program it blah
blah
they told me 75 but i think it was only
75
to copy the key because even the guy
that came in the van yesterday
he said it was 75 to copy the key but
then it's 55 to program it
yeah and then and actually i got it
cheaper because i
actually i had the actual key and he
could like just copy it
instead of having to pull the code to
like make the machine make it yeah
and every time he had to do something on
his laptop he's going to charge you more
money
yeah for that's in that some [ __ ] that's
some [ __ ] but you know what though
it's like yeah it's a good gig just
right around [ __ ] fixing people i was
thinking that too i'm like maybe i
should get into that
i'll be a mobile locksmithy person yeah
i mean because it did you could make a
lot of money company keys nothing i did
it back in high school working it only
took a few minutes that's a high school
[ __ ] yeah local store well now they
have like that really cool and
the machine is only like this big yeah
just fits in the back of the van and
then he's got like um he had like all
these little drawers like full of all
the different keys
like key blanks from like different
years and different manufacturers and
stuff
but everything fits like in the back of
a little van it's amazing how
how the robots and laptops that are that
can fit into a [ __ ]
la into a suitcase a small suitcase yeah
can okay i don't know if you guys you
guys some of you guys know what an ar-15
is that ar feet ar-15 lower receiver
you can put a block of [ __ ] aluminum
in
something that you can carry around and
plug into the wall the size of a
briefcase
and it'll make that lower receiver yeah
in about 20 minutes
it'll just sit there and cut it on its
own recirculating the lubricant and
everything yeah i was [ __ ] amazed
when i was a kid the tool that did that
weighed about three or four thousand
pounds
and had a [ __ ] you know like some a
nasa computer next to it
well yeah a computerized lathe and that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i was i was [ __ ] astounded that dude
made a whole
basically the legal part that makes an
ar-15
in about an hour and the robot just did
it on its own
yeah you know in a lap in in a [ __ ]
suitcase
yep yeah [ __ ] i mean i knew it was
going to be expensive like i said now
it's funny because
back in the old days like before when i
had my old car before they had chips and
all the keys and everything like for
anti-theft and whatnot
you could go to like walmart and get a
key cut for like three bucks or
something because i think i had to like
i got extra kicks it was like it was
like 350.
that was like years and years ago super
chat logan wanted to um
you wanted a logo and a policeman shirt
both in medium yeah logo and a polishing
shirt
yeah that but that's good because i
think i might already have those two
sizes
and we just printed some today a medium
yeah
send jenny a uh private message
let me get your address yeah we're
actually printing shirts today
yeah and we're gonna go to the mail
we're gonna go to the mail tomorrow so
yeah so this is you get in a couple days
okay
that's going to come up with some new
shirt designs in the next
week or so yeah i'm going to try to come
over and now we're going to try to kick
up some more interesting shirts i got
some cool [ __ ] coming some pair of
military stuff coming you guys are going
to like it
yeah and you know we've got lots of like
i said i want to get like a photo of
your face
is that crazy sit like so i can put that
on a shirt so you can say i say whatever
comes out of my mouth see whatever
what's inside my mouth
man i [ __ ] get a few drinks with me
and i [ __ ] say this crazy [ __ ]
only people in the [ __ ] comment
section notice it to me it just comes
out you know i say whatever comes out of
my mouth yeah
exactly it's the poultry guy saying it
i'm not really aware of it that's
[ __ ] hilarious but yeah
i feel so i feel bad because it seems
like a couple people just showed up but
it's like we've already been on for
like half an hour i know but yeah
seriously if you have shutter if you
don't have shutter i don't know why you
don't because
get it it's awesome um and it's cheap
but
if you do have shutter then immediately
go or wait till halloween because it
does like i said it does seem like a
really halloween type of movie
go watch the mortuary collection it's
really really good and it's fun
and i promise well i can't promise that
you'll love it because i know there's
going to be somebody out there it's like
i didn't love it you lied
but i thought it was awesome i had a
good time with it
like i said shutter has been added in
some like really good [ __ ] lately like
old [ __ ] and new [ __ ] so they've
they've been like really good they
usually like add all their best [ __ ]
what do we pay for that like five bucks
a month
it is i pay fifty nine dollars a year
fifty nine dollars a year so how much is
that a month
that is more or less that is less than
five dollars
but i think the basic entry cost it's
either 475 or 5.99
i can't remember a month yeah if you go
month to month but i pay by the year
because it was another ten dollars a
month
oh yeah and that and shutter dollar for
dollar pound for pound that fucker's
[ __ ]
it's really punching above its weight
that's a good that's a good service yeah
it's like they don't have like [ __ ] tons
of movies but the movies that they have
are like generally curated
right and they usually get um they have
like a lot of good classics and also
they have like people that are really
into horror that kind of
they try to get their mitts on like a
lot of uh festival stuff
that like you know did really well at
festivals though he's got everything
including [ __ ]
but yeah 2b is good for quantity
quantity not quality but you have to dig
through a lot of crap like to find goods
there is a lot of good [ __ ] on there but
you have to like go through a lot of
craft
shutter's only going to show you [ __ ]
that's got quality to it yeah
and and classic old stuff like zombie
and stuff like that you know
yeah old italian ones and they got
everything on there that's worth
watching
it's good or everything they have is
worth watching that's a good pretty much
because it's like pr
whenever they put something new up i'll
watch it i don't even care what it is
you don't care
it tends to be good yeah i was just like
oh they added two new movies this week
let's just watch those
whether it's new or old yeah the
curation's real good
yeah so i've seen like most probably
like 90
of the movies out there i've watched
them yeah if you don't have shadow get
that one and then they're not a sponsor
[ __ ] need to be sponsored
and we we got in that when they were
still kind of new
yeah and uh but i think they're kind of
rising to the top they're starting to
make a name for themselves
yeah and i definitely see like a lot of
uh advertising for them and stuff and
like i said they really do seem to get
their hands on i'd like to get a shutter
shirt
i got one but that's because they gave
me the offer
like when because i was paying month to
month and they said hey if you pay 59
bucks right now for a whole year we'll
send you a free shirt and i was like yes
please
was it did it look cool i don't ever
seen it remember it's like it's it has
like a little vcr on it
and it has like all these little vcr
titles with some of it it has like mandy
on there and all that
like a lot of their shutters you don't
wear it that much i don't think yeah i
do but it's like usually i like i wear
it walking out on the path
and stuff like that but yeah so it's
like i've worn it a lot so i wanted just
a black one with
their logo shutter you could probably
get one like that yeah
something that's playing you know but
high impact yeah yeah okay
but yeah the one i have has like a
little vcr and stuff on it so it's kind
of like a little
it's a whole design it's cool but yeah i
got it for free when i up when i upped
my subscription to like
paying yearly all right so uh we will be
back tomorrow
with another movie uh i think i already
have a plan of which one i'm gonna watch
it's another one that's on shutter
um it's a couple of years old but uh
we're going to talk about it tomorrow
we're going to watch it tonight and
we'll talk about it tomorrow
so we will talk to you guys again
tomorrow thanks everybody for stopping
by thanks logan for the contribution we
will print your shirts
today because i think i have blanks in
that size and
we'll talk to you guys later bye